welcome back to the show thank you for
joining us we have one of our favorite
guests here dakota von adams the
estranged son of stuart rhodes um the
founder of the oath keepers uh dakota
thank you for joining us again for some
of the updates that are in the news oh
thank you for having me on and in my bit
of shameless self-promotion and family
promotion i am dakota v adams on twitter
and
my mother is tasha adams which you
should also follow for
the latest closest possible
inside view
of the mind of stuart rhodes as we go
into the coming year
of oath keepers and stuart being
completely [ __ ] why i'm glad to have
you and i'm glad you plugged that is
there a website that the folks can go to
uh before we start asking questions uh
that way they know where to go not just
to twitter but to a website
begaltasha.com at her personal blog is
where you can go for updates on my mom's
book in progress
and her perspective on the oath keepers
related happenings that we're going to
see more and more of as the year
progresses and all of the secret santa's
workshop hours that the department of
justice and the january 6 committee have
been putting in
start to show up at our chimneys like
the prettiest best wrapped gifts you've
ever gotten right that's a perfect
christmas gift yeah i'm excited for that
santa claus to show up so let's get to
the questions let me ask the first
question here it seems like his paranoia
from the bundy ranch
has like
it's like you know that paranoia where
he was able to do a 180 flip on his
original mission of the oath keepers has
totally
done a 180 on like his whole reason of
to avoid prosecution for whatever
happened at the bunny ranch
yeah
so it's very interesting to
excuse me sorry it's very interesting to
think about it in terms of
like how bundy ranch kind of signaled
the point where stewart's self-interest
doomed the ideology behind oath keepers
because he
went missing in action for a long time
where people at bundy ranch had no idea
where the hell he was
and a bunch of money was unaccounted for
and i and there's no there's no telling
what happened to it the
oath keeper's money situation was
intentionally too complicated for any
one person to keep a handle on so
what
most
you mean by design steward
by design stewart did that that's why
you have uh 50 separate active bank
accounts that are supposedly going to be
tied to state chapters and then never
used
is to create
an intentionally complicated money
situation is that why he opened state
chapters you think is to create this
this layering of of organizations so it
was kind of like buffering away from him
or something oh that's how the
infrastructure was used later but uh the
state chapters happened because people
were independently organizing their own
state chapters
and then like oath keepers national was
finding out about them through events oh
so so so they were doing it without like
stewart's
and the oath keepers the national
keepers permission and then is that how
he kind of brought him underneath yeah
and then they started bringing them all
into an official structure and then the
state chapters uh became where he would
recruit
leadership for
the board of directors and national
positions like uh vice president chaplin
editor
uh people in charge of different
projects all of those and then they
would have to deal with stewart have to
deal with a project that required
stewart to do any work become incredibly
burnt out and then leave and then
eventually the state chapter people
started getting burnt out independently
because
uh dues sharing like the membership dues
money that was supposed to be shared
part way with the state chapters for
state level organizing
and events and expenses never happened
and the lack of communication with oath
keepers national and lack of backup
or lack of support for any state level
things unless stuart could grandstand
there and happen to be in position to do
so
that started to wear on everyone or i
believe there are still
a lot of oath keepers groups that split
off from oath keepers national that are
continuing
and going strong as independent regional
and and like state level or local
organizations
that are no longer affiliated with oath
keepers but started that way
but
the genesis of all that going wrong was
in bondi ranch where
uh stewart discovered a shortcut for
making a ton of money getting adelation
getting attention from people that had
more impressive military credentials
even com than he did even combat
experience
and higher education which was uh
pulling oath keepers operations like
the narcissistic supply and money
and
being a cool guy
like in a leadership position that he
showered himself with
during bundy ranch became incredibly
addictive and it was
the exact same psychology that you see
in like the guys who showed up to the
mauky were standoff
to treat it like a getaway from their
lives it was so much more fun than the
humdrum day-to-day
of doing nothing while you avoid the
work of running a national level
veterans organization so you think it's
kind of like a cosplay thing is that
what you're gonna see basically yes you
get that he got to cosplay effectively
as a
general this fantasy main thing does
fantasy where like the the tunnels that
we talked about before in the getaway
car and some of these other oh that was
all his personal paranoia that was
pre-ex that was pre-existing
i didn't know if it was all part of this
i didn't know this that was all part of
this cosplay this fantasy of that the
world would end and you know you would
have this where he would be the the
leader of the you know whatever
that actually
you actually you are right now that
you've now that i've let you phrase it
fully instead of interrupting you it's
uh
that fan the persecution element of his
grandiose savior fantasy right is what
led to
the escape tunnels and the paranoia
about felony stops so you got so when
you travel in a convoy and anybody doing
any kind of oath keepers thing always
had to travel in a convoy because it was
a way for him to be in charge of a thing
you had to space out enough that the
cops could only stop one or two vehicles
at a time and at a felony stop
checkpoint
and
all that [ __ ] but
it kind of
i can't remember the correct
pronunciation when a tumor begins to
grow out of control
however you pronounce it metastasized
yeah metastasized yes that is where it
began to get bad was bundy ranch and he
went through his deep dark depressive
hole
from people making fun of him for
pulling oath keepers out
to the perimeter and fleeing the ranch
when the rumors start to circulate about
a drone started being authorized by the
department of defense which is
completely [ __ ] ridiculous
yeah right that's like they only you
only get away with something like a move
bombing once you're not going to pull
off an airstrike on a bunch of white
dudes in the desert and get away with it
in the national eye well you know we see
this layering that you're talking about
like this this paranoia and this
layering
in in the january 6 story in recent
articles um we know there's an article
by politico i believe last month and it
talked about text messages and a trova
text messages that are basically
revealed
um from
stewart rhodes and other oath keepers to
trump associates like mike flynn and
roger stone and even even a congressman
uh
ronnie jackson i believe and there was
some more new reporting too
um also
about you know some of the orders that
were supposed to be handed down
what do you do you think that's all for
part of his
uh abandoning abandonment of having him
his own self not involved in some of
this layering where he's kind of at the
central point of it or i mean how do you
feel about that what that looks like to
me is what i thought
a while ago is that
stuart
would revel in the attention i think
of being in the inner circle and close
to trump you want to position himself
basically as far from
personal harm as possible
within
his overriding fantasy of being a savior
george washington figure
and starting from at the beginning of
the trump administration
the game plan was basically to take oath
keepers in a trump critical like
constitutional watchdog direction
where it was going to be the
kind of an iteration on the same game
plan for ifr romney had won instead of
obama in 2008 where it might be less
energizing than a threatening democrat
winning but this guy still needs to be
watched because uh
any product of the political machine is
inherently untrustworthy and the
president
should have his [ __ ] called out all the
time well you know that's interesting
that you say that because in the
previous uh times that we've talked
you've said that there was two different
directions that uh when stewart really
concocted the oath keepers he had two
different plans one if romney or excuse
me one if mccain won
one if uh obama won and then you're
saying
the romney election there's there's
another plan and then during the trump
election there seems to be another plan
so he's always he's always trying to
plan in scheme based on what the
national mood is exactly he is doing
exactly what he's always criticized
politicians of doing which is testing
the wind to see what's to see which way
the wind is blowing now he's basically
like a fair weather patriot it's kind of
yeah
and it's a good good phrase the uh if
the original plan had been stuck to
then he would have kept to the same line
of thought and then criticized the trump
administration
whenever it did anything
unconstitutional which would have turned
into a huge moment for oath keepers to
step into the spotlight as a bipartisan
check against totalitarianism like it
was supposed to be in the original
mission statement if they'd kept their
eyes on the prize
and not
drifted right into crazy town by the
time of
uh disguised federal task forces
abducting people off the streets during
the black lives matter protests and it
could have been like wow this is exactly
what we've been warning about hey
conservatives
the police i mean just like right now
with the all the proposed uh proposed
checkpoints to require uh negative
pregnancy tests of women before they
cross state lines under some of these
new state laws
that is a back door into implementing
the police state in a way where
gun-owning militia militia adjacent
conservatives will go along with it
until it's too late is how i would
phrase it right and that is exactly what
else keepers could have done but
stewart's self-interest in his fear of
being arrested by a democrat
administration over bundy ranch
caused him to cling increasingly to the
coattails of the trump administration
the proud boys going to the berkeley
protests brought in more money even if
he got mad that gavin mcginnis and the
proud boys kept getting top billing at
events and he didn't
and then
like i think
tasha has it right mom has it right
where she thinks that he got hooked up
with somebody when he was supposedly
pulling security at the maga ball after
trump's inauguration
and then as he became more and more
paranoid over what would happen to him
if a democrat ever took office again
there's this guy
there's this guy who's telling him they
can make everything okay if he can bring
his people on board
now in the past uh stewart had been
approached to be the paramilitary arm
of weird [ __ ]
and then turned it down because being
independent was more in his
self-interest at the time the last one
was a person i believe to be matt shea
because i know he was associated with
matt shea a bunch after that point and
went and spoke at the uh
marblehead community
and everything that matt shea is heavily
involved with this is the state
representative who had the internal
dossier in his office calling for
uh
a biblical war against communism and a
christian takeover in the united states
sounds like a really interesting fellow
by the way yes he's also just recently
been uh
in trouble for trying to
get
uh ukrainian children and uh separated
from their parents and orphans uh
shipped the united states from refugee
camps in poland without any paperwork
whatsoever and didn't want to give his
name to polish authorities
so matt shea is i probably to be adopted
out into proper christian households and
raised as stormtroopers like he is
in that side of it but somebody
in an evangelical christian group that
was somewhat underground approached
stewart
uh asking if oath keepers would serve as
part of their paramilitary arm if a
collapse came for creating
an american christian theocracy
that would take over in the absence of
the government and stuart turned him
down
but i think that was matt shea and he
kept contact with that matt shea after
that point even though it's basically
the same thing matt shape believes in
even if it wasn't the same guy
so that tells me that he was keeping his
options open in the background so even
if he started out being critical of
trump
on the constitution
he was going to keep that back channel
open
in case he needed a plan b
and then as he gets more and more afraid
of what happens if trump loses the
election
and there is
a liberal president
over the department of justice
what's going to happen to him and that's
where he starts to get sucked into
trump's circle and i do not believe that
he would have gone as far
as to be
the aggressor operating in a hostile
space like dc where in the past you've
been incredibly critical of
i can't remember the dude's name uh
i want to say fishbach but that's
completely wrong that's something
something people were talking him like
in a
calling him in a derogatory fashion he
was a
right-wing libertarian dude who was
leading
going to lead a second amendment rights
march on washington dc years in the past
and we're trying to find that got
shouted down so what what what what was
what was stewart's mindset about
washington dc exactly then like what
would he i mean i mean what was his
opinion on you know going into dc and
you know
like you said what was his objection to
it uh that it was a terrible idea that
would
start a civil conflict between the
right-wing militia movement and the
federal government in a position where
the militia movement would almost
certainly lose and look like the
aggressor thereby
immediately taking a defeat and losing a
huge chunk of popular support in one
fell swoop he thought it was the dumbest
thing he'd ever heard in his life
to take guns into washington dc as some
kind of political movement well you know
he thought that malheur was the
stupidest thing he'd ever heard of too
and then
he goes and does this he goes and
plots out the qrf and stashes weapons
across the potomac
with guys apparently
waiting to uh take the qr the armed qrf
across with the boat if necessary which
leads me to believe
that he had assurances
that he would not face consequence for
it right right and assurances from
someone who i don't know may
may be able to do something i don't know
maybe the word pardon comes to mind i
don't know right
but that's the other thing i wonder too
is like you know whether or not there
was actually actually direct
communication from trump to say roger
stone to
stewart you know i wonder if if roger
was like yeah yeah yeah yeah like i'll
i'll i'll do i'll figure it out and then
stuart like
unjust the trust of his word was like
great okay cool we'll shut that [ __ ] up
and we'll be ready to go whenever you
need us but there was actually no like
security
of
a pardon well i think there were
there are some people claim surfacing
that roger stone was auctioning off
pardons for tens of thousands of dollars
a piece and then was unable to follow
through with the problem the promise of
the auction pardons
there is the uh
witness testimony from the man whose
name i can't recall even though i should
who just pled guilty
stating that stewart called an
intermediary who refused to put him on
directly with donald trump you're not
talking about joshua you're not talking
about joshua james right you're talking
about the the newest oath keeper the
newest yeah the guy who says he was in a
hotel room when stewart tried to
personally reach trump over the phone
and got told no by the intermediary that
he would not be handing him off to speak
to trump personally for this phone
conversation
and basically left a message begging to
be called up to fight at 6 00 p.m that
day
when it when january 6 was winding down
it was clear that they had not won there
was the connection between and this is a
side thing joel greenberg joel greenberg
matt gates and roger stone
around pardons as well right um but that
obviously never never you know bubbled
up to something on the surface it was
just like
there i don't know if it was from joel
greenberg's camp or someone else but the
idea of auction off pardons was
something that was at least floated
within that camp
so yes to your point of what you're
saying like yeah obviously that is
totally on brand and then there's but
there is that element where i'm like is
roger stone just pocketing the money for
whoever the highest bidder is without
any sort of reassurances from trump or
even if he was like oh i'm i even spoke
to trump he was like i'll take your
money
and then i'm just gonna
hit the road you know i don't know if
you're asking the code of that question
yeah i'm not i'm just gonna say i don't
know if you're asking dakota that
question but i'll answer the question
hell to the yeah yeah that's that's
that's on brand for roger stone now we
don't i guess we'll find out maybe
eventually in federal court i think i
think the uh the person that you're
speaking of who has pled uh guilty uh in
in the
uh conspiracy here is brian ulrich uh
yes that is the third guilty plea in the
oath keepers specific conspiracy so far
he doesn't claim i don't in the
documents that i saw doesn't say that he
knows the identity of the intermediary
but that stewart called the intermediary
and asked to directly speak the trump
was denied
left a message begging to begging for
oath keepers and other militia groups to
be called up to fight um and this was
well after it was clear that
the coup had not gone off as planned
right because we talked about this
before because your assumption is
because because of where and how they
had the qrf stashed that and what the
mission looked like it appeared to be on
the ground and how they were acting like
their movements it really did and and
the fact that they were waiting for what
may be martial law to be declared um it
really looked like they were trying to
find or create some sort of chaos i
think that's the word you used in the
last time we spoke yeah some sort of
chaos that way they could they could
send up the order of martial law it
could be sent back down
and then they could
do the thing that they had planned to do
which was to
basically
[ __ ] on our constitution and and take it
to authoritarian rule at that point i
mean yeah keep trump in power right um
possibly arrest members of congress as
it becomes clear
that there probably was a plan to
just
abduct pence into the back of a trump
loyalist secret service vehicle and keep
him away from the capital
while the election
was
ruled decertified
right and then that didn't go off
because pence became incredibly canny at
the last moment and refused to bend on
the advice of dan quayle
so then the second chance the second
option is to
create um a giant street ball
brawl riot with the expected antifa
counter protesters and blm counter
protesters that everyone thought was
going to be there didn't show up create
a riot pitting trump supporters against
the capitol police and in the chaos of
that try to secure
members of congress as prisoners
right that way that way the ones that
avoid the ones that would vote to to not
sir are to to to not certify the
election
that would be the majority at that point
let me read you a quote um
from uh this npr article
from the court hearing where brian
ulrich actually pled guilty this is the
question that the judge asked in the
hearing uh the judge says did you do
that sir agree with mr rhodes and
develop a plan to stop the lawful
transfer of presidential power
by january 20th 2021. that was the
question
ulrich's reply was yes
your honor um so an open court is um
admitting that they were developing a
plan now
we're we're using we're using the
evidence that we have at hand to know
what the plan is i mean eventually um if
stuart were to go to trial this plan
will be laid out in front of us and the
evidence and the discovery will be
incredibly excited that the uh it looks
like the january 6th congressional
committee and the department of justice
have been working together this entire
time
what what what gives you what gives you
that sense what gives you that sense
it's
that was the recent article that came
out i believe it was uh regarding uh
subpoenas for records and subpoenas for
testimony
for the five members of congress
right that are that they're trying to
call up to be questioned and it was
revealed
that this is part of a series of
subpoenas
cannot remember the detail
from the article i've had a lot on my
mind it's been like stuff information
has just been falling
in one eye and out the other along with
uh
all kinds of statistical math that i
never remember again but it was that
they
also had department of justice people
right that were involved with the
interview process that had been filing
their own series of subpoenas
for
something that overlapped with
what they were specifically doing at the
time with subpoenaing these members of
congress
but was not
completely the same thing so that
implies
another overlapping investigation run by
the department of justice
with information sharing well you know
those five congressmen me and gabe
talked about him on the show the other
day they're kevin mccarthy uh jim jordan
uh andy biggs mo brooks and then what's
what's the last one what's the guy from
pennsylvania what's scott perry yeah
scott perry that's [ __ ] bucks um he's
he's another one that is in the subpoena
but um we've actually had um karen
agnipolo and michael popock on from
legal af and karen i think has
specifically told me and gabe
because a lot of people think that the
january 6 select committee has to give a
referral for crimes
and they don't like the department of
justice doesn't need the select
committee to give them a referral like
they can be running these investigations
and finding the same evidence at the
same time and the january 6 select
committee can actually be giving the
evidence to the department of justice
like it doesn't have to be this official
thing which we see with the contempt
charge
where they're trying to hold them in
contempt of congress which is an
official uh congressional thing that
they have to do
to do a referral because they have to
state hey you're in contempt now we're
referring it to the department of
justice right so this because the crimes
that are committed on january 6 are
outside of the january 6th select
committee and their contempt uh
jurisdiction so
people are kind of getting those things
like meshed up in a ball and i think
yeah there's what they're seeing and
what they're assuming is that the
department of justice will do nothing
and they're assuming that the committee
is a big congressional show that will
result in a strongly worded memo and i
don't think that's what's happening at
all well you know we're we're actually
me and gabe are gonna stream the uh the
public hearings and we're gonna try to
leave live stream them from front to
back um to try to give some commentary
and let the public see it uh as best we
can um and hopefully a lot of people
tune in to watch that not just for our
sake but to actually see what the story
is for january 6. okay i think that's
the confusing part about the story of
january 6
and and that it always seems to go back
to this one
focal point other than trump but the one
focal point that it always points back
to
is stuart rhodes like every single time
like enrique tario last time we talked
uh
the the proud boys leader at the time he
was uh he was hauled out of his house he
was indicted uh we we know we talked
about him and stewart meeting the day
before january 5th in a parking garage
um we talked about the prowl boys and
how oath keepers and proud boys never
get along and then you find out then we
find out here in the last couple weeks
that joshua james and this alright we're
all in communication and all with roger
stone who is supposed to have security
from the problems because a political
party was switched at the last second
right kelly makes kelly makes
one of the oath keepers from florida
kelly miggs actually discusses plans to
provide security for figures like roger
stones alex jones uh ali alexander mike
flynn and some of these people actually
didn't take the security but roger stone
did because we see evidence of joshua
james right next to roger stone um
during the january 6th the happenings of
january 6. so
this is very
inspiration right right it's very it's
very very uh telling that all this stuff
kind of leads back to
to stuart like he's kind of this central
focal point and there's always it always
sticks out in my mind dakota when we
talk to you and i talked about this
during marjorie taylor green tearings
because she was asked did you ever
advocate for martial law not the store
marshalls but like the
like martial arts like martial law how
it's actually spelled but she was asked
about martial law and i actually went on
a tangent during those hearings during a
break
where i always come back to what you say
about the qrf and why it was there like
why
why in the world would you need a stash
of weapons in a spot where you would
need it at hand at a quick notice
if an order would come down for anything
anything other than martial law like
what else is there reason to have that
across there if they were just there to
have aid to make sure
security to protect whoever like why
would you need a stash of weapons
across the potomac why and it always
sticks out in my mind like that only if
they were going to be forgiven after the
fact or death
or effectively deputized is a way to
freeze
up officially beforehand as trump's
personal paramilitary and i think why we
keep seeing stuart crop up and also why
my family didn't hear from him for
months on end is he no longer needed the
narcissistic supply
of
being in contact with his family to even
play at
being a dad because he was
soaking
in the supply of being in the middle of
this historic event
associated with donald trump and his
inner circle
and the reason why you see him
all over the place so often in all of
these events and all these people
talking about it
or uh very pointedly not talking about
it in the case of mtg
who uh can't remember anyone she has
ever talked to any place she's ever been
or what day it was over the course of
her entire life according to her
testimony on the stand
it's because stewart has
not only acted out of fear
and short-term personal gain in the
donations that being pro-trump could
give a flagging organization
but
has seen an opportunity to insert
himself
as trump's go-to guy for paramilitary
action his general in other words like
this general fantasy maybe like
his uh
his uh honorary general or chief of
real american internal security
incorporated or whatever the [ __ ] it was
going to be where it was going to be his
personal
brown shirt
essay division
for whatever he needed because the proud
boys
are street brawlers oath keepers if you
want a right-wing militia to back you up
in the middle of a gun fight
i would have called the real guys in
oath keepers before i would have called
for the proud boys proud boys have their
place in their niche role
stuart commanding oath keepers
could have functioned excellently for
whatever role they needed
an armed paramilitary to fulfill
without using federal police or the
military
and that is a position i think stewart
was intentionally trying to weasel his
way into
for trying to get the highest position
he could in the post coup
donald trump forever world well so so
the manga king thing is real
i think so i think that was in trump's
mind the whole time trump yeah all
positions of authority as basically
futile he thinks that
being the president everyone should have
ride or die personal loyalty to him
because he's a narcissistic sociopath
and he uh
like once he got adjusted having
presidential power
it's inconceivable of him to let it go
right right i mean january 6 was i mean
like obviously we have we have seen
signs of this throughout the presidency
but january 6 when you're sitting in
in your oval office for three to four
hours not doing anything you know in
terms of actually stopping it you know
then you see a video where he's like
i love you all
because in his mind he's like i i truly
love you all you are now literally
storming this building
because you want to keep me as president
because you're part of the legional yeah
he thought they looked too trashy he
would have liked uh better dressed
yuppier rioters
scary boat shoes and some you know
button-up shirts maybe you know he
wanted he wanted all the dudes
who almost get murdered over business
cards from american psycho oh he just
wanted a bunch of bros really he wanted
all of patrick bates co-workers to show
up in a riot for him because it would
have looked higher class on tv oh yeah
you i mean a high-class coup is
something that yeah it's an
authoritarian desires well i mean a
high-class coup has a different
different taste in your mouth than just
like a regular old coup you know he's
like yeah well last time the last time
we had one of those they uh all almost
got they all almost got killed by
spently butler it happens that way so
there's two there's two parts of this
story that haven't happened yet though
that i want to now then i want to get
your take on and you alluded to one
earlier but there's two things number
one
uh you you mentioned the fact that uh
stewart was terrified to go to dc that
the militia i thought it was really
stupid to take
especially an armed second amendment
protest
or an armed force into dc because
it would be seen as an aggressive act if
you start a fight with the police you
lose
especially if they corner you in on the
bridge
that the fish guy whose name i can't
quite recall was planning to march
across
so you're going to lose you're going to
look like the aggressor you're going to
lose public opinion at the beginning of
a civil conflict that you just
instigated you thought it was moronic
and not not only that you're saying that
he thought that it could be the end of
kind of right-wing militias in the
country in the movement so do you think
do you think the prosecution if and
that's my other question is do you think
stewart rhodes takes this to the bank if
he goes all the way to the end here he
goes through the entire trial does he
plead guilty that's my next question but
the first off do you really do do you
think that this
the insurrection the violent
insurrection where they're trying to
overthrow the constitution and make
donald trump the manga king do you think
that
um is going to absolutely permanently
damage not just the oath keepers but all
the militia groups out there because you
were raised in this culture and you know
these you know these people you know
them front back sideways and you know
how they act you know how these
organizations interact with culture so
tell us do you think that this is going
to damage them permanently or absolutely
i think so i think there are a ton of
people
who would absolutely not be down with a
right-wing dictatorship
and
what stewart was basically going to
accept in the bargain for saving his own
skin
and weaseling his way into a favored
position with dictator trump
is they don't really
most of these guys
specifically i won't say most of these
guys
what you would get continuing to support
that are the people who are willing to
support
a right-wing takeover a right wing like
to tell a talented ah
can't talk totalitarian takeover in
general are the hangers on
and the bottom of the barrel scrapings
the people that would be the most
dangerous opponents in a civil war i
don't believe are down
for
king trump being ruler of the united
states with the constitution suspended
right
especially now
that the catastrophic [ __ ] up
of
leaking the supreme the current supreme
court pending decision
drawing if this was an attempt to
distract everyone from the january six
uh
hearings and the trials that are
upcoming it was badly mistimed it's like
i said on twitter it's like a magician's
flourish with [ __ ] up timing that just
draws the eye to the switch of the cards
instead of distracting from it right or
like the smoke bomb and then you see
them leave the stage as opposed to
like the smoke doesn't dissipate enough
and it's just like a little puff of
smoke yeah like walk off
or you just jumped the gun and you
walked out ahead of the column of smoke
that was going to conceal your path to
the concealed back door
it's a horribly mis-timed
attempt to distract and now that
everyone is paying attention
it's going to completely wreck the
credibility
of the right-wing militia movement of
oath keepers of trumpism of all of it
with everyone who doesn't want
a
maybe theocratic
christian or maybe just right wing in
general
uh dictatorship
with a strong man who is promising to
fix everything and that means you're
going to get
not to say that the remaining crowd
isn't incredibly dangerous the remaining
crowd who doesn't want that there's a
lot of them they are incredibly
dangerous
but the people who would be
the most dangerous
are going to bleed out of the movement
and the gop
if
they continue on this path in fact i
think they lost a lot of people i think
the gop was already i think the
republicans were already on the road to
losing
a ton more voters than they expected in
the coming midterms
and getting hurt badly by their
continued association with trump
and now they've doubled down on it
i think i think yeah i think there's
there's a there's a few things that you
brought up over the last few minutes
that i think are really interesting one
whoever leaked it maybe jenny thomas
don't know and in terms
and uh
he's not saying but i'm not saying this
anytime so i'm just like if there was
someone that had some sort of uh
reason to to leak and distract you roe v
wade would be like hey listen i was
involved let's forget about january 6th
obviously like you said the time is
slowly off whoever that might be maybe
gina thomas maybe not
uh i think that is a very interesting
point and i think that you know with the
upcoming january uh sixth uh hearings on
june 9th and for the next eight eight
days or so whatever throughout the the
month of june i think is only just
ramping those efforts up because we're
looking
at a total breakdown of this country
right to say like we're you know these
people want a complete control over
women's bodies they want complete
control over uh the government or
decisions when it doesn't go their way
like people are beginning to actually
see like oh there's there's actually
this crazy-ass plan that they have
whether well-constructed or not
but then you have the people you brought
up which are like the ones who are
the most dangerous are the ones who are
going to deflect right and the way that
i see it in my mind are they look at
this whole situation as a means to an
end and i agree with you i completely
agree that those people are the most
dangerous because they have ulterior
motives in mind and the third thing i
think is that most hilarious of course
with the republican party
is just the complete hypocrisy and
projection which is i don't want a
police state i don't want a tyrannical
government i don't want anyone who's
totalitarian and then of course on the
flip side they're like i want to control
your body i want to overturn the
election and i want to say whatever you
say is the wrong thing and i'm always
right so i want to control or eliminate
public education i want to
get rid of gay marriage interracial
marriage ban condoms ban contraceptives
that are not for married couples right i
want checkpoints for women starting with
women crossing state lines
i want the laws of my state to apply in
other states that is a
really nice
callback to the
uh fugitive slave acts that was one of
the main causes of the civil war is
there is definitely
and it's also shown that the republican
party has been completely hijacked
by
this relative minority in the country
who desperately want these things and
just by agitating non-stop
and trying to work their way into
positions of power they now
control
the agenda of the entire gop
and the old guard have to go along with
it to preserve their positions and
preserve their careers and it's actually
a really neat looking road map
for a hostile takeover of the democratic
party for anyone who is sick
of the traditional old guard democratic
party acting like a helpless minority no
matter what the actual situation is
it's just if you organize with your
friends
and you don't stop trying to seize power
over the course of years and keep
showing up to all of the elections that
aren't big and glamorous and shiny
you can seize control shh don't don't
say that out loud what are you doing
you're giving away the game no i'm let
me let me tell you because you you two
have made some great points and i think
i think it's worth considering um some
of the things that possibly with this
leak of the
supreme court um overturning roe v wade
number one it goes back to the
constitution because these people are
they absolutely love it what is the
constitution yeah well they love talking
about it they never love actually what
it is or what it stands for which again
on this show we say the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
not liberty because liberty is what we
really strive for in this country the
rights and the freedoms are just the
thing that delivers you
the actual liberty and
i actually you know thinking about it
listening to you guys talk
if we look at the the
january 6 public hearings that are going
to happen throughout june we've heard
that there's going to be eight of them
it seems like that the supreme court
decision might have come down
during those hearings which maybe maybe
the right wing didn't want that to get
lost in their movement because a lot of
them at first were like yay we did it
and and they all of a sudden realized
that they had awakened this sleeping
giant right like they had realized oh
maybe this isn't such a great thing and
they're like leakily cool leaked it
right like that was their first
inclination was to pat themselves on the
back
and almost immediately they realized
that they had they had totally changed
the conversation to this
that actually the constitution is
something that is really important in
this country and what is happening is
the january 6 hearings the public
hearings are going to focus on
these people were trying to overturn the
document that protects your rights and
possibly the right to your bodily
autonomy like how important this is like
these people who are trying to
functionally take away your rights
through
functional government by
appointing supreme court justices that
seem to be bought and paid for to get to
win elections in congressional districts
and and the state legislators and these
governorships to erode away at your
constitutional rights wherever and
whenever they can
these are the people who wanted to
actually
overthrow the constitution and it
violently seized power right suspend
constitutional protections place the
country under martial law
under their control
and it's also going to be enticing
because it's going to raise the prospect
of the people
responsible for packing the supreme
court with [ __ ] lunatics the way that
it is now
facing
consequences for their many other
illegal actions
and a lot of people are going to be
paying attention that were not paying
attention previously and i think any
attempt to deflect
attention because now the narrative is
there
trying to equate
the protesters outside of the justices
homes right with the january 6
insurrection i'm hearing this repeated
by people who genuinely think
that uh january 6 was just a bunch of
old people wandering into the capitol
after the cops invited them in as i
don't see a bunch of protesters at the
supreme court justice house that are
smearing [ __ ] on their walls or
spraying their mace yeah
getting into shield while shoving
matches with riot cops and spraying like
this is not apples
this is a huge difference in comparison
and the only people that are going to
buy into that are so ideologically
suckered in right that they were going
to be showing up for the gop no matter
what anyway you know um no that's okay
because you brought up um protesting
outside justice zones but we've seen you
know the hilarity of some of this is
that susan collins called the cops i
want to show you a video of dakota maybe
you can react to it um this is
apparently
and i don't know where gabe found this
video he must have found it somewhere on
the deep dark found it on reddit
somewhere i'm sure that is the deep web
right so so but i want to show you this
video it it is hilarious um because it
seems to show the police officers
that showed up when susan collins
called because there was this sinister
sidewalk chalk let's let's watch
detective i just got senator calling
standing by the sidewalk she's very
concerned
he's working who detective johnson with
csi who called crime scene it's just
chalk on a sidewalk no chalk scene
investigation well i'm glad i arrived
when i did thank you sorry is this a
joke no but i'll tell you what is a joke
whoever decided to dust my chalk scene
for prince i was following a protocol
and i bet you also thought it was a
smart idea downloading the sidewalk note
in chalk yeah so jesus you might as well
just piss all over my evidence detective
you're going to want to see this coming
oh and uh while i'm gone try not to ruin
any more of my chalk scene
is this guy serious as serious as they
come it was assigned to the hopscotch
massacre of 2015. what he organized a
statewide manhunt for the sidewalk
chakra worked on it 24 7. but then the
case went cold and now he blames himself
for not solving it even ruined his
marriage well i've never heard of this
case we're trying
oh my god it was just a harmless talk
message supporting women's reproductive
rights you may think it's harmless but
politics
is where i do on the line
[Music]
shock scene investigation gabe i don't
know where the hell you found this video
i don't know i'm amazed that there are
people that use tick tock that are
old enough to remember csi miami
that's
i'm one of them
so so i think it's hilarious but but to
your point though
that that this this authoritarian rule
it does get clownish right like they
clown so much that the establishment
even susan collins herself clowns
herself by trying to you know trip over
her clown shoes to try to seem like oh
you know to sycophant to these people
i'm the victim i was the right i'm here
they were trying to attack me and it's
like susan
somebody wrote chalk on the public
sidewalk right like that kind of [ __ ] is
why it is so important to show up for
primary elections right not just the
protests but the elections is not right
it's the protest right because
if voting
was worthless
and this is something i see now that i'm
on twitter and i can be angry 24 7. uh
which is the real purpose of twitter
yeah that's what you imagine
yes right
much freedom speech it's about being
angry it's about being angry it's about
being angry non-stop and new being angry
in new ways but right i see all these
people going oh we've what do you mean
vote harder we already voted like no you
[ __ ] turned out for one presidential
election right in a last-ditch effort
to
plug the biggest hole at the bottom of
the sinking ship and it bought us a
little bit of time
right but
we're still pale in the water out of the
[ __ ]
we are still
on a semi-wrecked
schooner in the middle of a hurricane
everything's broken we're taking on
water the people that are supposed to be
helping us
bail it out
are
actively breaking the pumps
and stabbing the bottoms of their bodies
did we need that my bad you know right
like
oh my goodness
i love it i love your description of it
i love your description yeah half the
people on the titanic with you have
private life vests that they're pretty
sure will work and they all took out
insurance policies on the boat right
right right so what is happening now is
the consequence of all these people that
are like well we did vote not
understanding that to get us to this
point
the republicans
like the
hardcore my party is my sports team
tribe family and religion
conservatives who would cheer for a
dictatorship those ones
have been showing up for every single
election right
mid-term school board town council
state rep congressional
presidential
for 40 goddamn years right they are like
dog they elect fascist dog catchers
they're like that guy well i mean you
look at their group and they are you
know again just really good at
well [ __ ] messaging but they're
really good at nailing it home to induce
fear in yourself to be like well i don't
want to become a socialist bankrupt
nation like i want it to be american and
i want to be freedom you know free and
all this stuff but at the end of the day
it's like that's as democrats or as
liberals or whoever you are that's on
the left side of this on the aisle or
spectrum
you know
yeah exactly anyone who does that is a
very good that is a very good uh line in
the sand to draw if you do not want a
dictatorship you know this is where you
stand if you do then obviously you're
the the pro putin pro insurrection uh
mega trump king [ __ ] right but you
look at the people who
always go to the polls who always vote
right there is that fear that there is
that emotion that is driving them to say
i don't want this thing that my local
councilman or senator or whoever is is
is repeating over and over that it's
going to become this this crazy uh
socialist state or whatever it is
biden's going to steal all your baby
formula exactly exactly that's another
example but we shouldn't get babies
formula by the way we should give them
yeah no once they're born no formula
it's always both sides of the fence with
these [ __ ] listen you can you
gotta pick a lane and they won't well
they try to drive between the lane and
then you're like you're dangerous and
you're causing damage to everyone around
you and that's what they're like no no
no it's free well it's if you never pick
a lane then you're always right in
retrospect as long as you're using an
edited and [ __ ] edited video
compilation that's right that's what
that's what trump has always done and
and it's it's an easy way to draw drive
wedges right yeah and that's what that's
what the because you guys described as
the left and and dakota said right if
you're just against a dictatorship
because we've seen a lot of people even
in the public sphere that have been
pro-life for a long time
struggle with this leak and struggle
with this decision for scotus because
they're pro-life and they don't want roe
v wade but they know what it means when
this decision happens that it was an
authoritarian type of rule that put this
on the people of the united states no
matter how much they're against abortion
or why that the gop immediately sees
right to 100 telegraph what they
actually plan to do which i think is the
real mistake is instead of letting it
remain roe v wade they immediately
jumped on we're going to get rid of
interracial marriage we're going to get
rid of gay marriage we're going to
reverse [ __ ] all the way back through
browning v board of education back to
the decisions about whether the united
states can force you to not teach your
children
your native language as a first language
they're going to roll it all back the
state governments are going to [ __ ]
ban condoms and contraceptives and start
instituting checkpoints that demand
medical tests of you
and they made it so obvious at the front
that repealing roe v wade or overturning
it is only the first step in their wider
program that people that are single
issue on roe v wade are being confronted
with this massive wall of consequences
behind it that they would not be if
there were gop like the maga captured
fundamentalist gop
had exercised a little bit of patience
people might have let that slip under
the radar but they've become so
overconfident as a result of four years
of daddy trump that they can't do that
part of their brand that's part of their
brand is to always overstep to always
over negotiate to always over bid
you know um not to toot my own owner or
pat myself on the back but you brought
up banning condoms um i was one of the
first ones that said as this decision
came down like this is they're gonna
start you white dudes out there you
trumped up white dudes that go into a
gas station two years from now and you
want to get your condoms because you
want to get your [ __ ] on and and the the
store clerk's like we don't have condoms
anymore what are you doing they're like
what do you mean i'm kind of like
they're illegal like what the [ __ ] are
you talking these people don't
understand they really don't understand
what they're cheering on they have no
[ __ ] clue right they have no clue
what they're chewing on i also said that
elon musk won't ever own twitter and i
think i'm gonna be right uh so i don't
i'm gonna pat myself
we're gonna have no if we let these
idiots rule well no condoms
must go also never on twitter uh the
last question the last point i want to
ask you about uh before we go
is stuart rhodes taking this thing all
the way to the end zone i think he will
i think he will unless he gets a very
favorable plea deal and it looks like he
is dead certain to lose because he
remembers
um people from bundy ranch who skated it
when they went to trial so describe it
describe that describe that describe
that it's because
it's because uh like for example eamon
bundy personally
did not go to prison until after malheur
and then he was let off from that
because there was so many federal
informants
inside his inner circle at malheur that
it created
maybe not reasonable doubt but reason to
doubt that there was you did this of his
own free will and cognition
or and created a shadow of a doubt that
it was entrapment
and
he saw that
several times
people who did not take the plea bargain
had a shot so you're saying his
confidence comes from
those past experiences with these
paramilitia
type convictions and titles escaping
consequences when they went to trial
because of a specter
of federal informants and entrapment
which
is something unless and federal agencies
are going to have to learn is that
the [ __ ] that they do when they're in
trapping
uh muslim men into bomb plots that are
99 federal agent right will not work in
a court of law prosecuting a christian
white guy it's just a simple fact is the
precedent set
in
nabbing
muslim men that are vulnerable to
radicalization and
uh far left groups and environmental
groups and eco-terrorists like do what
you're saying like while we've been on
this call or while we've been on this
chat right now there was a mass shooting
where 10 people were killed by an
extremist manifesto leaked online like
while we've been talking this whole
thing is happening [ __ ] jesus christ and
but it is an example of you know a
christian white guy escorted in cuffs to
the to the police car nothing you know
no connoisseurs didn't buy him burger
king this time i mean or was it i think
they i think they got him a a happy meal
maybe they bought him i mean you know
what what what was the one cop he said
uh about uh he was yeah he he was
disgruntled he was he was discouraged
this person also is a self-described
white supremacist and anti-semite and of
course
totally he went on his shooting spree
yes it was in a supermarket he went on
his shooting spree in buffalo new york
in a grocery store in a predominantly
black area so that he could kill black
people yeah and he
threw a bunch of he threw a bunch of dog
whistles into his manifesto which i
would not recommend you read because
it's kind of worthless
just to
the they were all things that he saw
from previous white supremacist
manifestos i think that he saw got media
attention
so i think he's kind of like a like a
copy cat copy kicker he's a copycat he
is
a gestalt copycat
of everyone under the sun who was a
white supremacist mass shooter including
dylan roof and just cribbed [ __ ] from
all their manifestos and jammed it
together it's bordering on a plagiarized
manifesto so he basically wants his name
he's a white supremacist he wants his
name out there as well yeah the sad
thing is that's what we do in this
country we make yeah we are who are
the perpetrators of mass shootings and
then we wonder why we have a problem
what was the last time there was a
school or a mall shooting in switzerland
or finland where there are
the only like two of the only places in
the world where there are as many
semi-automatic rifles floating around at
random as there are in the united states
it doesn't happen because we have a
cultural problem yeah right
i've said that before i've said and and
really um you know to your point there
and and i grew up in white america i
grew up in rural white america it is and
you know a lot of people might knock me
for this but it is a white culture
problem this is a white gun culture
problem where white males think that
they own everything they cannot be
punished i mean we see it inside media
even like like even joe rogan on his
show he's always talking about how i get
to get you got you used to get to would
do anything you wanted like that's not
freedom you don't get to do whatever you
want that's not [ __ ] true you've
never been able to just drive down the
road at 500 miles an hour you've never
been able to just speed through a stop
sign only if you weren't get caught you
can't just punch someone in the mouth
because you don't like them at the
grocery store like you can't do whatever
you want that is all [ __ ] just
because you think you have the
entitlement and the privilege to do
whatever you want doesn't actually mean
you do but maybe you're alluding to the
fact that maybe they do do and um you're
saying that stewart's mindset of his
trial may be that he does have that
privilege he does have the right to do
whatever he wants and it's that white
gun culture type mentality this this
entitlement the history of gun control
and
the massacre of fringe groups nobody
gave a [ __ ] about the move bombing
people who live i
about to make myself sound ignorant if
it's not philadelphia that was
philadelphia right i you know you got me
um it was a
fringe black group
that
took up residence inside an apartment
building
and refused to leave and holed up in
there there was a standoff the police
ended the standoff by dropping dynamite
from a [ __ ] police helicopter and
burned down two city blocks
nobody who people grew up in the city of
philadelphia and never know that it
happened yeah i don't i've never heard
of this either and the probably the
reason why is because of who they was
perpetrated against black people yes
exactly people the uh gun laws
the beginning of the trend in gun laws
that eventually led to
uh
the atf and the fbi killing randy
weaver's family started with
reagan coming down on the black panthers
exactly right yep
don't don't bring those guns in the
building here in the country
the worst most egregious gun laws in the
whole country everyone loves to lay at
the feet of liberal democrats the reason
they are the way that they are the
reason why
they are structured in a way that is so
intentionally confusing
changeable and meant to create obviously
as many felons who cannot vote as
possible is because the original
template was to [ __ ] with black people
by the hand of ronald reagan so you have
these things
where
law enforcement people inside law
enforcement get away with a thing
they get away with the philadelphia
police get away with bombing an
apartment building and burning down to
city blocks and killing a bunch of
people
they get away with
gun confiscation to [ __ ] up the black
panther movement they get away with that
[ __ ]
and then somebody inside the feds tries
to use this against
white extremists and it all goes to hell
and creates an enormous cultural
firestorm it's because i think
federal law enforcement forgets about
white privilege because they have a
blind spot for institutional privilege
because in all honesty
i'd say
federal police agencies are in no way
immune to being affected by it so they
don't want to acknowledge that it's real
so they fall prey to it even in trying
to prosecute cases and that's where you
get people
walking away
after the malheur standoff because of a
level of informant involvement
that would not have even been considered
noteworthy if they were muslim
extremists and carried out the exact
same actions
and that
so in a way
these of this effect of
white militia dudes getting away with
[ __ ] that they should not have been able
to given the precedent of what charges
stick to non-white or muslim people has
created the confidence that stuart
rhodes has that he will be able to go
all the way through trial turn it into a
circus get his name all over the media
and then walk away with his image
rejuvenated with the right wing
well i i think i think stewart is uh
completely dead wrong about that and i
think oh he's completely [ __ ] right
i think i think he's capital f-u-c-k
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] because he's not he's not
just [ __ ] um in the legal trial but
when we see what we're going to see on
january 6 because i would suspect that
the words oathkeepers and stuart rhodes
name comes up several times in the
public hearings and it's not going to be
good for stewart and it's not going to
be good for anyone who's associated
with those public hearings dakota thank
you for joining us again
please come back as these uh january 6th
select uh committee hearings develop as
the news with these oath keepers if we
get more plea deals from these oath
keepers um you know we we always
appreciate your insight not just into
the news but also into the mind and the
culture of the militia and what it means
what it means for
our our country like what what what is
it going to be if are we going to be
authoritarian are we not so i appreciate
you joining us thank you everyone stick
around we will be right back after these
messages buy the products yeah